bom dia
eu queria começar essa palestra com três
perguntas podem levantar a mão sem
vergonha
quem é que tem um celular com câmera no
bolso todo mundo né
quem aqui tem uma conta no instagram
nossa quase todo mundo mas nem todo
mundo aqui
quem aqui já fez uma foto hoje
nossa eu achava que vocês estavam
melhores do que o resto do mundo mas
pelo me pelo que estou vendo aqui vocês
estão bem próximos do resto do mundo
vamos ver um vídeo
[Música]
o fã
quanta foto né vocês devem estar se
perguntando mas quem é esse cara louco
que fica fazendo fotos de gente fazendo
foto é uma pergunta que eu sempre faço
também quem é esse cara é louco quem sou
eu porque você precisa saber agora é que
enfim o fotógrafo antes mesmo de ter
nascido depois eu explico melhor isso e
que esse é o fator land um trabalho que
eu faço desde 2010 mas o que que é isso
o que que é o fato além
na verdade a fotografia é hoje o maior
hobby do planeta a fatura depois da
popularização das câmeras digitais
mais recentemente pela explosão dos
smartphones
a fotografia ficou muito acessível a
fotografia na palma da mão todo mundo
tem um celular no bolso ea gente
fotografa o tempo inteiro sem fazer
distinção do que vale e do que não vai
liberar uma imagem
então nessa palestra que eu vou tentar
falar primeiro tentar explicar qual
sempre foi a nossa relação com as
imagens e como isso vem mudando depois
vou contar um pouco da minha história
o que a gente precisa entender é que a
fotografia sempre foi um instrumento de
memória a gente usa as imagens pra
pontuar um acontecimento o tempo um
aniversário uma viagem um batizado né
momentos importantes merecem uma imagem
atualmente não mais um momento especial
merece uma imagem
mas todos os acontecimentos merecem uma
imagem
os ordinários inclusive e o que os torna
acontecimentos é o fato de eles serem
fotografados
vou tentar explicar melhor eu como
sempre fui fotógrafo desde antes de
nascer eu sempre tive uma relação muito
intensa com as imagens
então quando eu não estou trabalhando
sempre vitor fica fotografando o tempo
inteiro
eu fui fazer uma viagem à argentina
recentemente com a minha namorada e tava
bem chato com isso assim não queria
fotografar nada e ela até hoje me cobra
fábio
quando é que a gente vai poder fazer uma
viagem de verdade porque aquela não
existiu
enfim é o que o que isso quer dizer é se
quer dizer que a gente está mudando a
nossa relação com as imagens agora se
todo o acontecimento é importante se
tudo merece uma imagem
a gente se desconecta um pouco com a
nossa relação entre passado presente e
futuro
é como se houvesse uma ampliação do
tempo presente né
estamos cada vez mais ansiosos para uma
próxima imagem que defina a nossa
existência daqui a cinco segundos né
tudo é relevante e ao mesmo tempo nada é
relevante
então a gente está mudando nossa relação
com o tempo e agora eu queria fazer mais
uma pergunta pra vocês
a foto que vocês fizeram hoje ontem ou
anteontem ela de fato era relevante
eu acho que vocês podem responder
internamente
então a experiência em si está cada vez
mais virando um modo de ver né
estamos fotografando cada vez mais e
trocando a fotografia pela experiência
então a fotografia que sempre foi um
instrumento de memória está verão um
dispositivo de esquecimento
fotografamos não mais para salvar o
instante
fotografamos para sermos salvos do
esquecimento numa repetitiva infinita
seqüência de instantâneos fotográficos
estamos virando uma paisagem
autobiográfica
estamos virando uma fotografia como se
vocês aí e eu aqui estivéssemos na nossa
melhor por
casual
agora vou contar um pouco da minha
experiência com as imagens
eu fui o primeiro bebê no brasil a
passar por uma ultrassonografia
eu já gastei os meus quinze minutos de
fama antes mesmo de eu nascer e acho que
é por isso que eu gosto de ficar atrás
da câmera porque me lembra um lugar
confortável protegido o útero materno
essa foto mostra eu velando um fifa
mudou eu velando um filme para desespero
do meu tio fotógrafo aos três anos de
idade
essa mostra a capa de uma revista que
durou 30 anos no brasil que a revista e
eles foto que ela pertencia à família da
minha tia essa revista influenciou uma
geração de fotógrafos dos quais eu fiz
parte também eu freqüentei a redação ou
seja fotografia sempre fez parte da
minha vida aqui sou eu no banheiro
fazendo uma foto um self né
aos 12 anos de idade quando eu ganhei a
minha primeira câmera e logo depois eu
virei fotógrafo
fui ver anda já nascer e como vocês vêem
eu sempre escondida atrás da câmera mais
ou menos aos 20 anos de idade eu me
profissionalizei eu era uma espécie de
fotojornalista estava sempre no meio dos
acontecimentos estava sempre no meio das
confusões
eu gostava mesmo de uma treinar lina aí
um dia já trabalhou no jornal o meu
editor vira pra mim fala assim fábio eu
tenho uma missão para você
o fotógrafo que faz retrato aqui no
jornal faltou e eu preciso que você faça
uma foto da maria bethânia e falhar
sossegado né
acabei de voltar de uma manifestação vou
lá fotografar betânia tranquilo
bati na porta ela me recebeu abriu a
porta assim olhou pra mim e falou você
tem um minuto para fazer essa foto
nessa hora a minha perna bambeou mas
encarei na fla
fiz a falta da betânia voltei para o
jornal foi revelar o filme a ficou
horrível
a foto ficou péssima tomei uma bronca do
meu editor mas de alguma forma aquilo me
chamou atenção de alguma forma
sou pra mim como uma espécie de desafio
e eu fui pedindo cada vez mais para
fazer fotos de retrato e eu passei os
últimos 20 15 anos da minha vida batendo
na porta das pessoas me apresentando ou
eu sou o fábio eu vim fazer sua foto
isso tem vez por dia e construir uma
carreira mesmo como retratista assim já
fotografei tudo quanto é tipo de gente
que se possa imaginar artista presidente
enfim anônimo famoso tudo é e aí no ano
de ser mais ou menos de 2009
eu estava de férias em paris em câmera e
fui ao louvre e entrei na sala da mona
lisa e lá eu me deparei com a cena mais
surreal que eu vi na minha vida e
comecei a ver na maioria chineses
japoneses querendo se degladiando
desesperados para fazer a foto do quadro
mas eu pensei gente
todo mundo conhece a mona lisa é só
fechar os olhos já vem o sorriso da mona
lisa né
e pensando comigo assim eu falei caramba
acho que isso merece uma imagem e desde
2009 a cada viagem que eu faço
aproveitou para fotografar o projeto já
fiz várias palestras exposições vi a gp3
continentes vários países tudo por conta
do fator índia no ano de 2015 mais ou
menos um outro editor que eu trabalhava
me liga e fala assim fábio
eu tenho uma missão para você a maria
bethânia está fazendo 70 anos e eu
preciso que você faça foto que a gente
vai dar um caderno especial aqui no
jornal
confesso que a minha perna bambeou né
fui lá bate na porta da betânia antes
mesmo dela falar falei betania eu vou
fazer a sua foto em um minuto
sentei ela
ela baixar a cabeça sim pensar em todas
as coisas importantes da vida dela os
desafios e as conquistas e as
dificuldades
tudo que ela passou e quando ela
levantar seu rosto ela obedece um olhar
de quem está fazendo 70 anos
e aí eu fiz essa foto é uma foto simples
nem acho grande de coisas assim foi capa
do jornal
não levei uma bronca dessa vez mais de
alguma forma essa foto mexeu comigo
primeiro porque eu me vejo muito nesse
olhar é como se fosse uma espécie de
autorretrato e depois porque comecei a
questionar minha própria carreira né
eu comecei a minha carreira fotografando
como retratista fotografando betânia e
15 anos depois né e mesmo que você não
queira você acaba fazendo um ciclo né
e aí eu comecei ao mesmo tempo né onde
agora todo mundo tem uma câmera no bolso
eu comecei a ver a minha própria
profissão perdendo a relevar assim eu
sempre fui muito escondido muito tímido
nunca postava as fotos dos meus
trabalhos nem eu comecei a ser esquecido
e aí que comecei a entrar em uma
profunda crise existencial
eu acho que foi ladeira baixo mesmo
assim comecei a ver a minha profissão
ficando meio à deriva
só que nesse momento eu já tinha
planejado a última viagem do projeto que
é para o país chave dessa história de
acesso de imagens que é o japão e lá na
terra do sol nascente
eu tive uma espécie de epifania andando
no meio do lado do japão eu comecei a
perceber que eu não tava fotografam dos
outros
eu estava me fotografando
eu estava olhando para o meu próprio
ofício e me questionando e fazendo a tal
pergunta quem sou eu
e lá
pode ir lá do outro lado do mundo
aconteceu coisa que mudou a minha vida
eu comprei um pau de self pode passar e
entendi que eu tinha ido pro japão para
fazer um harakiri a e matar o fotógrafo
eu fui até o japão para morrer
muito mais do que para fotografar o fato
além disso e foi nessa época que eu
comecei a fazer uns elvis foi nessa
época que eu comecei a ver que não
necessariamente eu gostava de ficar
atrás da câmera e eu sei que isso tudo
parece um pouco contraditório primeiro
eu falo que a gente está vivendo um
universo de excesso de imagens uma
megalomania desenfreada e depois eu falo
que eu gosto de ser exibido que eu acho
de aplauso que eu gosto de aparecer mas
na verdade o que eu acho que aconteceu
comigo foi que encontrei um equilíbrio
agora eu sei quando eu devo abaixar a
câmera e quando eu devo me expor
agora eu sei quando eu devo fotografar
ou quando eu devo viver e eu acho que o
que a gente precisa fazer cada vez mais
isso acham equilíbrio colocar quitéria o
meu critério é quem sou eu essa foto me
ajuda a entender quem sou eu fotografo
vocês têm que achar o critério de vocês
e agora eu queria fazer um desafio que
todos vocês pegassem o celular e colocar
se assim na frente do rosto sem vergonha
gente sem medo eu tô aqui expondo vamos
lá coloque em frente ao rosto ativem a
câmera como se vocês fossem fazer um
self
vamos lá coloque a seguir à frente do
rosto não fotografei ainda e eu quero
que você faça uma coisa fechem os olhos
passa o filme da vida de vocês na cabeça
pensemos maiores desafios nas maiores
dificuldades nas maiores conquistas
pense no que levou vocês a chegar até
aqui e quando eu falar já não agora
ainda vocês vão abrir os olhos e fazer
uma foto
vamos lá então calma sustentem essa
emoção no olhar
o projeto tem essa emoção no olhar e
quando desejar
vamos lá 1 venceu na vida a dois
em tudo 3 e já faça uma foto
guardem essa imagem
eu tenho certeza que essa imagem
ela é muito mais próxima do que vocês
são do que a imagem que você projeta no
mundo
lembrem-se dessa imagem porque ela vai
ajudar vocês a entender quem são vocês e
eu queria agora é terminar essa palestra
de um jeito um pouco inusitado fazendo
um self aqui no palco do tet falou mais
uma minuto ligado gente obrigada a
entregar
[Aplausos]